welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and while watching the big game we
just got a new trailer for The Flash yes
this movie is still coming June 16th
starring Ezra Miller as Barry Allen and
another Barry Allen in this DC
Multiverse movie that has been years in
the making and still happening we're
gonna have at least two Batmans in this
movie and yes I'm with you it is crazy
that this is happening I'm gonna explain
how it fits in with James Gunn's
recently announced big plan for the DC
Universe and what we can expect from
this film but first let's react to this
trailer quickly though reminder Friday
February 17th will be the launch day of
our new channel the Deep dive in which
I'm going to be doing more Focus
investigatory analyzes and things like
everything everywhere all at once also
Friday noon Eastern 9 A.M Pacific I'm
gonna be doing a live breakdown of
Batman The Lost Corner Mania you can
subscribe and deep dive in R and you can
support the new Rockstar's Network by
checking out our merch options at nerd
riot.shop like this Quantum media
inspired shirt rain Eternal but let's
react to this trailer
tell me something
another timeline that's Keaton
Another Universe
oh so why do you want to stay there
can't be bail it wasn't fake this one
this is the world where my mom lives
I'm not gonna lose her again
Bruce I could fix things you could also
destroy everything this is kept me
happening this can't be happening wait
that's I completely Metropolis on zod's
attack hey why we've been waiting for
you what Zod I created a world with no
meta-humans
and now there's no one to defend us
oh damn
you're
you are yeah
I'm Batman
oh my God
what is going on
that looks like fails if I can't but
that's not fair that's gotta be back
oh damn there might not be a future
what's the plate Batman what do we do we
try not to die cut this I can't believe
he's back
oh so that's para right my name is Cara
yeah Barry
what I mean I guess I should have been
surprised I knew this movie was coming
I've done videos about this movie in the
past but you know with all the
controversy surrounding Ezra Miller we
just really weren't sure what the plan
was with The Flash movie but now it got
me back to it we can't be that surprised
I was just out of the contrary my
honeymoon and I went on Netflix over
there and I was shocked to see all the
stuff that normally is there in American
Netflix but not where I was that's why
it's so important to use nordvpn with
nordvpn I could switch my virtual
location on my device with one click
letting me access streaming services
from over 60 countries at no extra cost
this opens up a smorgasbord of stuff to
watch that I wouldn't be able to access
without nordvpn nordvpn is also the
fastest VPN out there so you won't have
to sacrifice speed for sake of your
shows it's what we use at new Rockstar's
offices let me tell you it's fast for
the price of just one cup of coffee a
month I get to have premium cyber
security on six devices and gain access
to streaming services from over 60
countries at no extra cost it's also
available on every platform to grab your
exclusive ignored VPN deal go to
nordvpn.com new rockstars to get a huge
discount off your nordvpn plan plus a
bonus gift nordvpn is a 30-day
money-back guarantee so you can try
nordvpn completely risk-free just click
the link in the description to get
started okay so a quick explanation of
how this Flash Film is going to fit in
with the DC Universe going forward James
Gunn recently did the whole big
announcement about what the DC slate was
going to be and his old plan for phase
one of his Gods and Monsters plan a lot
of exciting titles including a Green
Lantern's True Detective series we're
gonna have a new Superman film in 2025
there's gonna be a new Batman and Robin
but before that we have these four 2023
films that were already on the docket in
this movie The Flash was supposed to
come out years ago but it's just been
delayed and delayed and delayed but
James Gunn has said he is very excited
about this movie and it's gonna be the
movie that resets the DC Universe it's
gonna Bridge what we previously knew as
the DC Universe from the Zack Snyder era
the DC EU but also obviously connecting
back to previous era as the Tim Burton
ERA with a Michael Keaton playing Batman
this is what the flashpoint Paradox is
if you aren't familiar with the
flashpoint pair Paradox was a big event
in the DC Comics around 2011 that
crossed over with these other else
worlds in which the flash Barry Allen
goes back in time to try to prevent his
mother's murder but in doing so is it
one reality where Bruce Wayne died and
Batman is his father Thomas Wayne it's
just a really really cool crossover
story that connects the dots in a lot of
fun ways and introduced what's called
The New 52 the the 52 DC characters that
they were going to follow at that point
forward it was really their way of
cleaning house it's going to use this
event in this storyline to multiversely
clarify any of the confusing or
convoluted or contradictory DC timelines
on film that we've seen before so it
sounds like it's going to start in what
we knew as the dceu as both Affleck and
Ezra Miller played the characters in the
Justice League film or Justice League
films because they're you know obviously
the studio version the Zack Snyder
version now is that Universe going to be
the exact Snyder verse I don't know if
this movie is going to draw a
distinction between the two but we do
know in either case the Barry Allen
entered the story with his mother
already dead his father was already in
jail for the mother Nora Allen's murder
in Barry had promised that he would
prove his innocence one way or another
also in the Snyder cut of the judge this
league they did a lot more to explain
how Barry Allen's time reversal Works
those were my favorite parts of the
director's cut they also added some
dialogue that made it make a lot more
sense it sounds like what we're gonna
see in this movie is Barry going to at
least one alternate reality and that one
alternate reality is the one where his
mother is still alive and he meets the
alternate Barry the one with the
headphones he's right outside his house
it seems like they lived a happy life
beyond that there's something particular
about this reality where things went
down differently and he's going to
investigate it and it sounds like this
is the same reality in which Batman
Bruce Wayne is played by Michael Keaton
is it the Burton verse in particular I
don't think Tim Burton really has any
strong canonical boundaries to his
Universe this is just a universe where
Michael Keaton played Batman also seems
like this is a universe that does not
have Kalel Superman but rather Supergirl
who is Kara zorel a biological cousin to
Kalel but with a different story a
different history actually we're gonna
get a separate Supergirl event later on
in James Good's plan that I'm very
excited for but here she's gonna be
played by Sasha Kaye and I'm really
excited the way their character moves is
very similar to the way the kryptonians
moved and Man of Steel and Batman vs
Superman in the Justice League trailer
looks like they're keeping her in some
remote snowy prison maybe not too far
from where the Kryptonian ship crashed
just a reminder that in Zack Snyder's
Man of Steel there was one cryopod that
was left open that he said that he
planned to readdress at some point in
the future hinting heavily that it was
Supergirl in that universe but Barry in
this trailer says that in this universe
there are no meta-humans but it looks
like there is one meta human but the
others don't exist I'm super excited
we're going to be revisiting the events
of the 2013 Man of Steel storyline and
which is odd attacks Metropolis I think
there's a chance for some Redemption
here you know that was a heavily
criticized scene of all the collateral
damage you know hundred thousand people
in Metropolis who would have lost their
lives now here's Barry's chance to save
most of them I mean look I just love
Michael Shane and Zod back on screen
again this is super exciting now you
probably saw a lot of shots of uh Batman
on a motorcycle here this is not
Christian Bale's Batman at least I don't
think he kind of has a Bluer Cape the
more stubby ears pretty sure this has
Ben Affleck Batman but he drives a
similar motorcycle at least with a
similar sound effect I just love seeing
that Ben Affleck isn't only going to be
limited to the early parts of this movie
before Barry leaves that reality that
we're going to see a lot of action from
bat flick I think this is going to be a
very solid goodbye to an Era that a lot
of people still really loved of the DC
movies we here at new rockstars are
going to go back through this trailer
frame by frame and do a proper breakdown
of all the details and Easter eggs that
you might have missed but until then
we'll leave it there from this reaction
let us know in the comments below your
favorite part of this trailer what
you're most looking forward to be sure
to subscribe to our new channel the Deep
dive it's launching this Friday with
five five premium videos that you're
gonna love you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at a boss fall
into rockstars And subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]